I know you've probably edited this out
so that people can't hear what you just
said so I'll just repeat what you said
for the people that are watching this
right now which you said and correct me
if I'm wrong Ant-Man is the most
powerful important character in all of
the MCU and the biggest uh and best
Avenger is that right
well he said it on me but I'll go with
that
[Music]
Anchorman
it's called Sex Panther by odion it's
illegal in nine countries well I played
Brian fantana in Anchorman he's the
field reporter and he has Geraldo Rivera
kind of look and a whole bunch of
unearned confidence as do all of those
guys in that Newsroom unearned
confidence and they're all kind of dumb
where the hell's a suit store we've been
walking for 45 minutes brick I thought
you said this was a shortcut fantastic
Ryan fantana's guy is pretty impressed
with himself or likes to present himself
that way but is you know just
staggeringly insecure and uh trying his
hardest to look like the smoothest dude
out there
it's rare to read a script that it's
just so fun to read just you that you
want to reread it for pleasure and
certainly with comedies I did that with
wet Hot American Summer and then I did
that again with Anchorman I thought
those were the two funniest scripts
sixty percent of the time works every
time
that doesn't make sense and they were
funny for similar reasons and their
absurdity and how meta certain things
were and how it was so unlike everything
else probably why they both had trouble
getting made and the reception was
confusion for a lot of people but
Anchorman was one that I just thought oh
my God this is the funniest craziest
most specific
story Will Ferrell and Adam McKay they
write together it's it's just
Bliss
era
so it was a while before they I was cast
in it I think in a few months and I was
just
on the phone every few days with my
Asians going and you heard anything
it's not in the early way that I am but
I was with that we met before we started
filming to rehearse improvise some
scenes or or just kind of Riff Off of
what was in the script I had had
experience with improvisation but never
on a big Studio movie I mean I was
pleasantly surprised when we started
shooting and then will might just go off
in some direction and I'm not prepared
for or McKay would be behind the monitor
yelling out lines you know he and will
had worked together obviously in on SNL
and they had a way of doing things and
Judd Apatow was a producer on it and
Judd had a way of kind of working in
this style so we would always do what
was in script but then we'd start kind
of messing around it was a whole new way
of working on a big budget movie and it
was thrilling there are so so many times
in Anchorman and scenes that I had such
clear memories of laughing I didn't
expect will when he said I'm proud of
you fellas you all kept your head on a
swivel and that's what you got to do
when you find yourself in a vicious
cockfight that's not in the scrap script
or anything I and I was like took me by
surprise you don't want to laugh when
you're in someone's take because
you don't want to make something
unusable and if it's really funny and
then somebody laughs and you can't use
it it's it's really annoying and so
there's always a pressure not to laugh
that being said I think this scene that
we laughed the hardest it was the first
time I think creating the crew was
getting a little annoyed because we just
couldn't get through it which was a
scene of all of us sitting around a
table plotting how we were going to take
down Veronica Corningstone and will is
asking brick what he's eating and brick
says oh
it's one of those
delicious Falafel hot dogs with cinnamon
and bacon on top what do you mean one of
those those don't exist I mean that's a
used coffee filter with cigarette butts
on it and I remember looking at it and
it was coffee grass but it was like
chocolate cake a little like coffee a
real coffee filter like a cigarette butt
a wrapper and then a dime and every time
Corel would take a bite of it it was so
repulsive we'd all start laughing we'd
have to do it again and then the build
up became funny because will would then
say how we break what is that you're
eating and as soon as you just come by
by the way brick if he didn't even get
out what are you eating he said
it was the pause and then noticing and
then we'd all just start laughing
40 Year Old Virgin
you know when you're like you grab a
woman's breast and it's
and you you feel it and
it feels like a bag of sand
when you're touching it
bag of sand
you know what I mean why don't we just
play you want to just steal the cards
what are you talking about Steve had
this sketch that he had done at Second
City that he'd written about a 40 year
old virgin actually the sketch was It
was kind of recreated in that poker
scene but it's a bunch of guys that are
sitting around kind of telling Tales out
of school about how you know women
they've been with things they've done
and one guy who's like oh yeah and it
becomes clear that he's never ever been
with a woman you know and that turned
into the movie you're a virgin I am shut
up how does that happen Abby now works
with Judd a few times we'd spend a lot
of time before adding things to the
script filming improvisations that would
eventually make their way into the
script you know by the time you start
shooting one of those movies you have a
200 and some odd page script when it
came time to actually film sometimes we
would take it upon ourselves to start
improvising did you ever see a school of
rock yeah well this is uh it's called
School of
you know oh it's like it that's nice
Judd would say all right do more of that
keep go back and say that he'll yell
outlines and we'll be in the middle of
scene we'll just repeat what he says or
maybe another writer will say something
and they become these kind of
collaborative kind of jam sessions
really and when something really
Cooks like when it's really when when
it's working you can tell and it's
thrilling because nobody including us
like knows exactly what it is we're
gonna say or what's going to happen or
where it's going to go to hopefully find
a few moments here and there because
there's a lot of you know most of it
you'll never use and you wouldn't want
to use it cool just the one right here
right Hi how are you so this is your
first time getting body walks when Steve
was getting waxed in that scene he
really was so
the girl who actually did it said that
her family owned a salon she did this
and I was like I don't think that was
true I don't think she'd ever done it
like one of those things where it's like
an actor hire an actor was like can you
ride a horse I can ride a horse can you
exit chest I can totally wax a chest
you that one hurt that one hurt just as
much the first one that's great man
you know we were playing into it
obviously I don't know if that's if it's
true Romney really did get queasy and
wanted to leave but I mean it really was
like you could tell it was painful we
set up like five cameras because once
you know you did it you weren't gonna go
back do it again yeah Steve's hilarious
and he knew how to scream and make it
funny and you're coming up with jokes on
the Fly too I mean I think just a
pattern which he was waxed it's like he
did look like a pumpkin so then it's
like you look like a mano Lantern this
is not a good look for me you look like
a mano Lantern thank you very much
there's always this kind of somebody
with a pen off to the side writing
things or sometimes you don't want to
say what you're gonna say and you don't
tell anybody if it works it works and if
it doesn't it doesn't
I love you man
I'm glad you called we get home safe
pistol
you got it jobin
I'm sorry what all right first work with
Jason on knocked up and I knew Jason
also because he'd
worked with Judd way before me and and
this way of working I think we found
that we enjoyed working with each other
that way John Hamburg had written this
script and I remember thinking this
premise is brilliant I can't believe
this hasn't been done I'm just like a
buddy film but it's really kind of in
the structure of a romantic comedy John
met with both Jason and I at the same
time like yeah let's do this this is
this would be really
I think would be a blast it was so much
fun doing that movie and there was such
a such a joyous feel on it I think
because Jason and I like started we
could complete each other's senses and
as far as any kind of joke or any kind
of dumb little thing that somebody might
think of the other guy wouldn't bat an
eye and take it go with it in some other
direction you're wearing a tuxedo think
James Bond all right give me give me
some James Bond
no it just looks like you're pointing at
me I think we both really loved the
characters we were playing I loved
playing that character awkward
insecure she
thought all that stuff is really fun to
play probably comes a little too easy to
me because I relate to it too much
[Music]
how's that feel Rush was in the script
and the reason was because John Hamburg
when he was in high school
had a band and Rush was his that was the
the band
[Music]
you know both Jason and I knew Russian
loved Russian this would be the perfect
band that these guys would share a love
of this band and then it was just so
fortuitous because while we were
shooting the movie Rush was on tour and
they came to LA and they had two shows
and there was a day in between each show
and they said all right yeah we can come
by we'll shoot a scene
you know I probably hear it a little
less now than I did at one point in my
life but I think more than any other
thing yeah I slapped the base is
probably the line that also has just
walked down the street and I'll hear
somebody yell it from somewhere slap at
the bass Mommy you're slapping the best
man there you go slap at that
[Applause]
Bassa please don't do that or somebody
else you know let the rain go
Slide the base I know I've met a few few
bass players in my life that want to
strangle me like dude you ruined my life
that the joke
Clueless
hey James Bond America we drive on the
right side of the road I am you tried
driving in platforms look I gotta get
back to school uh wanna practice parking
what's the point everywhere you go has
valet when I first read the script for
clueless I thought okay this is going to
be another movie about a bunch of kids
and seem pretty smart I was really kind
of into it as I was reading it and I
thought all the characters were unique I
had been asked to read for Josh for that
for the part that I played but I when I
went into the audition I said you know
this part's really something really
funny about this part that I I'd love to
try for that one they said sure read for
whatever whatever you want but I said
well Murray's really funny and then they
said well actually that's an
African-American part I said okay well
then I won't refill that one but uh then
they said what would you would you read
for Josh the one that you got the one he
was supposed to read for in first place
so well of course I would I just got
here and already you're playing couch
Commando hey in some parts of the
universe maybe not in Contempo casual
but in some parts it's considered cool
to know what's going on in the world
preparation that I did for John I went
to college and I think I just lifted
most of my own clothes for that movie
some of those clothes that I was wearing
with causes on it that was my Amnesty
International shirt and it was my KU ad
the having a bit of a goatee kind of
growing it in and having it for a little
bit then that was gone hey granola
breath you got something on your chin
growing a goatee well that's good you
don't want to be the last one at the
coffee house without Jim pukes very true
to I think my own college experience
audience so I was certainly lucky enough
to make it through several rounds and
get cast in that movie
can you imagine the nerve of that guy
I mean making you worry like that
he's the one that screwed up and then he
goes and blames us I want to say that
scene on the top of the stairs we were
kind of working on it as we were filming
it that day I was very self-conscious
afterward
are you saying you care about me
Josh
as far as that kiss goes I think my
manager at the time after when the movie
came out and said oh I was not good he
said I did not do that very well so I'm
like hey you weren't there how would you
know it's a weird job when you're hired
and part of your job is to kiss somebody
and I was very aware I was kissing the
girl from the Aerosmith that he goes and
that there was going to be a lot of
dudes who are going to be very jealous
of me I was very aware of that
Knocked Up
what's so great about bubbles they float
you can pop them I mean I get it I get
it I wish I liked anything as much as my
kids like bubbles that's sad when we
were working on the script Judd and
Leslie had bitten married and together
for a long time has had my wife and I
have been together for a long time up
until that point you know Jed wanted to
hear
things from my life and my marriage and
things that we you know we were dealing
with and being a young parent there were
certain things like I never when my wife
was pregnant I didn't read the baby
books and we got into an argument about
it she took it as a hostile gesture
which I totally understand retrospect I
said what did the cavemen do without
what to expect what you're expecting and
I told all the suggesting that was funny
and then it's in the movie Now Is Seth's
character you didn't even read the baby
books I didn't read the baby book what's
gonna happen how did anyone ever give
birth without a baby book that's right
the ancient Egyptians engraved
What to Expect When You're Expecting on
the pyramid walls I forgot about that
and when my wife and I saw the movie
cheese
she's like oh so this is an interesting
documentary we're watching right now I
literally am at a point where I don't
know what I can say so I'm the bad guy
because I'm trying to protect our kids
from child molesters and mercury and
you're cool because you don't give a
yeah yeah is that it
pretty much God you're an it was
the first time that we had worked
together Leslie and I and I think the
very first scene that we filmed together
was when we're in the bathroom
foreign
and then we did we got into a fight I'm
just really constipated
do you really want to
well now and Leslie is such a good
actress I went home that night I was
like oh my God I think Leslie is really
mad at me I think that she
I think she maybe hates me and really
kind of rattled me a little bit somehow
I got back and the next day Leslie
came over to me and she goes I heard you
think that I'm mad at you I said I'm
just I'm I didn't I hope not because I
didn't I didn't want to upset you she
goes of course not I don't hate you my
God I hate Judd
you know oh yeah no we're we're gonna
have a blast
there are five different types of chairs
in this hotel room holy what are
they all doing and these are five
different types of chairs get them out
of here man set design had there was it
was like a hotel room they were
cherished around I thought like how do
you act like you're peeking on mushrooms
or how I like it isn't like drunk or
high or something like I don't know what
do we think shoot let's let's just put
all the chairs together
and then like all right now go guys
oh man we knew we were gonna get to this
idea that can you believe like that
somebody would ever want to be with you
to marry you so we had an end point I
think we knew we were gonna kind of
say which was about how we would get
there we didn't really know and those
chairs would just happen to be props in
the set that they had built and so we
just pushed them all together and we
just kind of started rolling it can't
accept love
you don't know what it is love the most
beautiful shining warming thing in the
world you can't accept it I have to go
to this other chair
oh this is a better energy
[Music]
it's 40.
what is she doing okay oh my God oh my
God oh my gosh
don't do that what am I doing don't fart
in the bed you know it's I've known Judd
and Leslie and the girls for years and I
knew them when they were babies really
and I went over to the house one night I
was just like I have dinner and see what
their night is like you know how their
evening kind of goes they're like all
right I'm gonna go put mod to bed or
Iris to bed and read him a story or I
was just kind of an observer but I also
knew them so it was a yeah we spent a
lot of time together up until that point
so it wasn't like I was some stranger
kind of taking notes at the end of their
bed it all sounds so Daniel day-lewisy
doesn't it I'm gonna go put the kids to
bed I did by the way I remember
going to their room and they had a
machine that projected stars on their
ceiling and they're like oh yeah they
don't sleep without this without this
Star machine on then I went back and I
ordered two star machines off the
outside and I still have they're great
to build tree houses and play with
sticks nobody plays with sticks you and
Charlotte can have a lemonade stand They
Kick the Can look for dead bodies it's
fun that's fun to do get a tire and then
just take a stick and run down the
street with it nobody does that crap
it's 2012. you don't need technology no
technology it was a weird feeling to do
these scenes where I'm acting opposite
his wife with his kid standing there and
he's off you know filming it all he's
very aware of how
strange I mean I kept trying to think
how are his children processing this is
this healthy is what we're doing here
right now safe and good
with time and distance I could say yes
and it was a really
fun experience I had a great time
working on the movie I've had a great
time working actually on all the movies
with Jack I think they've been really
really fun and they're as far as
creatively I think they're some of the
most fulfilling creative experiences
because of the collaboration because of
the freedom that everybody feels
I think and what they can do and what
they can maybe try and come up with
Wet Hot American Summer
you're gonna clean that up
oh yeah I will
um I just got I don't have time right
now clean it up and come to my office
for the meeting
I gotta
are they making Wet Hot American Summer
was a blast it was the first thing
but I think that a lot of the people
that were working on it it really spoke
to our our kind of collective
sensibility and senses of humor hey
my girl
write my thoughts in it every day
Oh you mean a journal hero kind of knew
each other a little bit it was like all
these kind of New York actors and improv
comedy and the old comedy C and we
filmed it at a summer camp we had to
leave in the middle of production
because the camp was closed for a week
because somebody hired it out to have a
bar mitzvah you know we all slept at the
camp it rained every day so whoever
wasn't filming had to go into town which
was about 30 minutes away and buy beer
so that when the days filming was done
everyone we all hung out we wouldn't
have computers like we don't want to
like cell phones really it was just it
so we were everyone was just there and
also if you weren't working you went and
watched other people filming their
scenes so there was a real kind of
camaraderie and affiliate like a
collective it was like being at summer
camp and so to do that and then work on
material that we all found funny that we
kind of couldn't believe was actually
getting made and we all kind of knew
people are not going to get this but I
think that people who do get it or will
find it's funny we'll find it really
funny what is it you have barbecue sauce
all over your
obviously anything I work on I don't
know I don't know if something's good or
bad I really don't I always go in with
like the best intentions but I do know
that like when wet Hot American Summer
was done
I'm like this movie's funny I know it's
funny I'm and not I'm laughing at the
parts of just like when they jump out of
the truck and they run over to the side
of the building and stand there just
stand there and it makes the cup
[Music]
I just dying I think that's like the
funniest thing and so that when you know
yeah when it came out people like well
this is just seems like a bunch of Hit
and Miss jokes and it doesn't really add
up that was the first time I'm like no I
actually
well I I don't agree with that opinion
Forgetting Sarah Marshall
are you uh are you Chuck oh man you know
they won't change that
that's my Mainland name my Hawaiian name
is kunu
oh cool sorry yeah ah it's all good does
kunu have some like cool Hawaiian
meaning it means Chuck I'd worked with
Jason Siegel a couple of times I love
Jason Stoller again all the people I've
worked with in the past and there really
wasn't much in that script necessarily
about that character and Jason said come
down and play a surf instructor you know
if you ever go to these resorts in
Hawaii there's always somebody that is
working there and they're super cool and
they're gonna take you out and teach you
how to surf or teach you how to scuba
dive or whatever it is and you spend
half a day with him and it's like this
person has really got everything kind of
figured out what a great life the cool
thing and then he spent a little longer
and you learn a little bit more about
their lives and there's the running from
something of broken in some way and this
guy has a daughter it's like yeah you
know I haven't seen her a while but
that's that's cool she's on her own
Journey
which is these these kinds of sad
statements I think I was in my 30s I was
like so I was 44 I remember thinking
like that's super funny really old 44. I
mean if you had to put a number on it I
guess I'd be 44.
and so a lot of those scenes I mean
all of them really I know what I was
gonna say what I was gonna do and then
we're all we all figuring out like we're
all there on the beach like what if we
just keep get up that's too much no down
like there's no Rhyme or Reason to
anything the guy is saying yeah we were
weighing them
Ant-Man
would you like some sugar yeah thanks
you know what I'm okay my friend Edgar
Wright he'd written a script with Joe
Cornish he asked if I would be
interested in playing this part I
thought it'd be fun to try and play a
role that so different than anything
that had really played I mean the idea
of a superhero was really intriguing and
great I mean these things are seen all
over the world and by all ages you know
this that's a somewhat new experience
for me hey
you're cute
foreign
that was a lot scarier a second ago the
first two were more Standalone smaller
kind of separate from from everything
else it didn't really have the huge
spectacle maybe of some of the other
big Marvel movies and and this one kind
of does in this new version in Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania it is such a
huge film I mean just the scope of it
the scale of it and how it's kind of
kicking off this new phase with the
introduction of Kang What's it gonna be
Batman you know one of the most
incredible experiences I've had working
on the Marvel films is getting to meet
Stan Lee and one of the things that he
told me was how happy he was that they
were making Ant-Man as a film he felt in
the comics
it was very tough to really gauge the
scale if you're drawing hey man you
can't really draw other things at the
proper scale so audiences were going to
finally see Ant-Man in the way that he
always envisioned Dan man
[Music]
to working within the MCU and these
films you do feel a part of a collective
in a way there's something pretty great
about that you know when you're an actor
it can be kind of a solitary existence
and when you feel like you're kind of
going through it with a group of people
it makes it fun I feel like real solid
friendships form I kind of can't believe
that it's been
now almost
nine years is that right Selena yeah